what we're going to do in this video is
talk about the powers of the President
of the United States and we're going to
broadly divide them into two categories
formal powers are those that are
explicitly listed in the United States
Constitution and we're also going to
talk about informal powers a little bit
in this video and a lot more depth into
future videos the formal powers are
listed in article 2 of the United States
Constitution and it starts in section 1
where it says the executive power shall
be vested in a president of the United
States of America and this simple
statement alone has a lot of
implications as we will see it is used
as a justification for many of the
informal powers of the president the
president is the executive they run the
government Congress can pass laws and
set budgets judicial branch can
interpret laws or declare them
unconstitutional but the executive power
is vested in the president but the bulk
of the powers are listed in section 2
and section 3 so let's read this
together and let's see if we can
classify these different powers as
executive legislative foreign policy or
military or judicial powers so section 2
of article 2 starts off with the
President shall be commander in chief of
the Army and Navy of the United States
and of the militia of the several states
when called into the actual service of
the United States so this is clearly a
military power you have the President of
the United States being in charge of the
nation's military it then goes on to say
he may require the opinion in writing of
the principal officer in each of the
executive departments upon any subject
relating to the duties of their
respective offices so this is clearly an
executive power or an administrative
power where he can go to the head of any
of executive departments and say hey I
need your opinion on something
potentially in writing then it goes on
to say and he shall have power to grant
reprieves and pardons for offenses
against the United States
except in cases of impeachment so this
is a judicial power grant reprieves and
pardons for federal offenses then we
read he shall have power by and with the
advice and consent of the Senate to make
treaties provided two thirds of the
Senators present concur so this power to
make treaties is clearly a foreign
policy power although it does have to be
ratified by the Senate and he shall
nominate and by and with the advice and
consent of the Senate shall appoint
ambassadors other public ministers and
consuls judges of the Supreme Court and
all other officers of the United States
whose appointments are not here and
otherwise provided for and which shall
be established by law but the Congress
may by law vest the appointment of such
inferior officers as they think proper
in the president alone in the courts of
law or in the heads of Department so all
of these lines your talk about the
president's power of appointment which
is why I underlined it in the executive
or the administrative color although it
touches on appointments that affect
these other powers so for example the
appointment of ambassadors is clearly
going to have foreign policy
implications and judges of the Supreme
Court this could have huge judicial
implications so I will underline that in
blue as well it then goes on to say and
this is in relation to the appointments
we just talked about the President shall
have power to fill up all vacancies that
may happen during the recess of the
Senate because remember it just talked
about how the Senate has to confirm
appointments but the President does have
the power to fill up vacancies while the
Senate is in recess while they're not in
session by granting Commission's which
shall expire at the end of their next
session and then in Section three we
read he the president although it could
be a she shall from time to time give to
the Congress information of the State of
the Union and recommend to their
consideration such measures as
he or she shall judge necessary and
expedient he may on extraordinary
occasions convene both houses or either
of them and in case of disagreement
between them with respect to the time of
adjournment he may adjourn them to such
time as he shall think proper so these
are always these are all powers that the
president has in the legislative process
and then it goes back to foreign policy
he shall receive ambassadors and other
public ministers he shall take care that
the laws be faithfully executed and
shall commission all the officers of the
United States this statement he shall
take care that the laws be faithfully
executed in conjunction with what is
sometimes known as the vesting clause
which is at the very beginning of
article 2 section 1 that simply States
the executive power shall be vested in a
president of the United States these two
clauses combined have been used to
justify what we will see are called
informal powers which we will go into
much more depth into future videos
especially the power of the executive
order and so in summary if we want to
look at the executive powers of the
president the power to take care that
laws be faithfully executed nominating
officials with confirmation from the
Senate request written opinions of
administrative officials fill
administrative vacancies during recesses
then you have the legislative powers
present info on the State of the Union
recommend legislation to Congress
convenes on extraordinary occasions
adjourn Congress if House and Senate
cannot agree and can veto legislation
although Congress can overrule with a
two-thirds vote and then you have the
foreign policy and military powers which
include being commander-in-chief of the
Armed Forces making treaties which have
to be ratified by the Senate nominate
ambassadors receive ambassadors and
provide diplomatic recognition to other
governments and then finally the
judicial powers that we saw in article
two reprieves and pardons for
federal offenses and the power to
nominate federal judges including US
Supreme Court judges now as I touched on
these are the formal powers but there's
also what are known as informal powers
and we'll talk more about these in other
videos the president has a unique role
in the federal government and in
national discourse as a whole and
because of that they have a lot of
bargaining and persuasion power now as
we also touched on we have an informal
power of executive orders which is
derived from the formal powers to take
care that laws be faithfully executed
and the fact that the power of the
executive is vested in the president you
also have things called signing
statements which we'll do future videos
on which is when a law gets passed by
Congress the president can issue a
document known as a signing statement
which interprets that law and as you can
imagine and that interpretation of the
law could be very very influential and
then you also have executive agreements
these are agreements with foreign
governments that do not have to be
ratified by the US Senate so they're not
formal treaties but they can be
agreements with governments so I will
leave you there as you can see the
president has many tools at their
disposal to influence the policy-making
process
in future videos we will talk more about
these especially the informal powers